since his debut in 1962 spider-man has
been one of the most popular superheroes
in the world and he's also one of the
most well known but with countless
spider-man stories built around some
pretty confusing plot points it's easy
to get mixed up let us have the great
responsibility of clearing up a lot of
incorrect things people believe about
spider-man of all the original Marvel
Universe titles the amazing spider-man
is one of the most strongly identified
with Stan the man Lee even though he'd
be a part of all of Marvel's early
string of hits including The Avengers
the x-men the Hulk and more Spidey was
the character he stuck with the longest
scripting the first 100 issues and then
staying on sporadically for another few
years after you know I guess one person
can make a difference
enough said if however you think Stan's
the only one responsible for the thrills
of those early adventures you're
mistaken
most fans are aware that Lee pioneered
the Marvel style of writing in which
he'd collaborate with an artist on a
loose plot then add in the dialogue
after everything else was done what's a
little less well-known however is that
his relationship with artists and
spider-man's co-creator Steve Ditko was
one of the first to deteriorate
according to Marvel Comics the untold
story the latter chunk of Ditko's 38
issue run including the legendary story
that gave the world the iconic image of
spider-man fighting his way out from
under a massive heap of rubble was
produced without Ditko and Lee speaking
to each other at all
[Music]
of course that doesn't mean lien wasn't
a necessary ingredients for spider-man's
early success the fact that he stayed
with the character for almost seven
years after Ditko's departure and kept
on producing some of the best years of
spider-man is a testament to how
important he was to the character and
how well he got along with dick coast
replacement jazzy John Romita the one
thing about spider-man that's always
been true is that underneath that mask
is always Peter Parker just an average
everyday scientific super genius with
problems just like ours you know like
juggling our long-term relationships to
supermodels while making a living off
selfies that's why it's always been
Peter except for all those times it's
someone else while Peter Parker has
certainly been the main man in the mask
at spider-man since Spidey's debut in
1962 he's definitely not the only one
for a while in the 90s spider-man was
instead Ben Riley a clone of Peter made
by a villain called the jackal right
around the time Peter temporarily lost
his powers Reilly was tricked into
thinking he was the genuine article he
dyed his hair blonde got a job at a
coffee shop and took over the role with
a new costume for the entirety of 1996
before eventually dissolving into a pile
of dust
more recently Peter found his own
consciousness overwritten by Doctor
Octopus who took over his life as the
superior spider-man beyond just
variations on Peter Parker's body and
enough alternate universe versions that
they have their own special team there's
an entirely different spider-man in the
Marvel Universe Miles Morales who
stepped into the spotlight in 2018 into
the spider-verse a movie based entirely
on teaching us that anyone could be
spider-man if they never give up
including Gwen Stacy Nic Cage and a
talking pig it can get weird
one of the most intense arguments you
could overhear in a comic book store
back when the first spider-man movie
came out concerned whether spider-man's
web shooters were mechanical or an
organic byproduct of his spider powers
going by the comics though it doesn't
matter what side of the argument you're
on you're wrong either way when Sam
Raimi's film hit theaters one of the few
notable changes that it made to
spider-man's origin story came with the
addition of organic web shooters this
proved to be so controversial that when
the next movies were announced in 2010
the decision to use the comics
mechanical web-shooters literally made
headlines after all he'd never had
organic web shooters in the comics or at
least he didn't have them in the comics
before those movies came out after their
success a 2005 storyline called
the other ended with Peter being eaten
by a giant spider in emerging with
organic webs those didn't last either
they inexplicably disappeared with the
back-to-basics approach of the brand-new
day story two years later but other
Marvel Universe Spider characters
retained them in fact Cyndi moon a
classmate of Peters who was bitten by
the same radioactive spider is so
capable of spinning her own webs that
her super heroic code name became silk
one of the defining tragedies of
spider-man's life was the death of Gwen
Stacy in the 60s she was the love of
Peter Parker's life forming a
complicated love triangle with Mary Jane
Watson and providing the backbone of the
soap opera that underscored his Spidey
super heroics an amazing spider-man
number 121 the Green Goblin kidnapped
her and used her as bait to lure
spider-man into a battle at the top of
the George Washington Bridge and while
the story title wasn't revealed into the
last page the night Quinn Stacy died
lived up to its name the Goblin is
definitely to blame for Gwen's murder
he's the one who took her to the top of
the bridge and the one who threw her off
all in an effort to torture spider-man
if however you really want to get
technical about things he's not the one
responsible for what literally killed
her
that sad honor goes to spider-man
himself it's easy to miss but the real
tragedy can be seen in the issue when
Spiderman tried to save Quinn by
snagging her leg with a web line as she
plunged toward the Hudson River the
sudden stop proved to be the fatal
moment a small snap sound effect next to
Quinn shows it was a broken neck from
Peter's attempt at saving her that
actually ended Quinn's life spider-man
doesn't kill its one of the absolute
rules of the character and unlike other
heroes he's lived up to it too in over
50 years of comics spider-man has never
actually killed anyone himself except
for the one time he did it happened in
the pages of spider-man vs. Wolverine a
1987 one-shot by Christopher priest and
Marc bright that pulled Spidey into a
dark world of international espionage
the conflict between the two title
characters is largely built around a spy
codenamed Charlemagne who is described
as Wolverines best friend from his days
as a government operative in this story
Charlie wants Wolverine to kill her so
she won't be apprehended and spend the
rest of her life being tortured in a
gulag when spider-man stumbles into this
situation all he knows is Wolverine is
trying to kill someone in the fight that
ensues Spidey unleashes his full
strength on the x-man hitting him with
blows that would wreck cars
sadly Charlie takes advantage of the
brutal conflict tricking spider-man into
hitting her instead of Wolverine using
him to commit suicide Peter was
understandably traumatized by the event
and while he and Wolverine have made
peace in the year since it was a source
of bitterness between them for a long
time the iconic image of Peter Parker is
of a young man struggling to make ends
meet by working as a freelance
photographer selling snapshots of his
own super heroic exploits to the Daily
Bugle to satisfy Jay jonah Jameson's
demand for pictures of spider-man if
that's your only concept of what Spidey
does when he's not out fighting crime
however it's time for an update the
truth is while Peter worked for the
bugle for decades in a lot of classic
stories he hasn't actually been a
freelance photographer for most of this
century starting in 2001 Pete returned
to his old stomping grounds of Midtown
high as a science teacher but that
proved to be a pretty short-lived career
choice in the years since he's had a
couple of science related jobs working
for a think tank called horizon laughs
where he reverse engineered his
crime-fighting gadgets into consumer
goods he even founded his own
multinational corporation called Parker
industries although technically it was
Otto Octavius who founded that company
while he was in Peters body and Peter
had to destroy it to keep it from being
taken over by Nazis comics are
complicated
one of the more controversial moments in
spider-man's comics history involved a
deal with the devil like the literal
devil not just this guy
after Peter revealed his identity during
the events of civil war his family was
targeted by bad guys who nearly killed
Aunt May which was a good reminder of
why he had the whole secret identity
thing to begin with unfortunately for
the Parker family that sort of reveal
isn't the kind of thing you can undo
unless you're willing to make an
infernal bargain with Mephisto which is
exactly what happened rather than
selling their souls however Peter and
thin wife Mary Jane Watson sold their
marriage effectively erasing their years
of wedded bliss from Marvel Comics
continuity as though it had never
happened in the spider-man comics Peter
and MJ were both freed up to pursue new
relationships but don't let that fool
you into thinking the marriage is
completely gone in order to go along
with the comic book storyline the
spider-man newspaper strip did away with
the marriage as well
readers reacted so poorly however that
in the strip that rain on May 24 2009
the elimination of the marriage was
revealed to have been a dream ever since
newspaper Spidey has remained happily
married or at least as happy as anyone
can be when they spend most of their
time getting knocked unconscious right
next to Dilbert everyone knows that
Peter Parker was orphaned at a young age
and raised by Aunt May and Uncle Ben
considering that his surrogate parents
were about as wholesome and
salt-of-the-earth as people could be it
stands to reason that Richard and Mary
Parker were cut from the same cloth just
average ordinary folks right wrong in
1968 it was revealed that when the
Parker parents died they were under a
cloud of suspicion as traitors to their
country the truth however was that they
were spies working for shield who had
infiltrated the red skulls criminal
organization before being killed without
ever getting the chance to clear their
names yes in case you missed that
spider-man's parents were spies who were
murdered by Captain America's
arch-nemesis if that's not weird enough
they later turned up alive only to be
revealed even later to be robot
duplicates that's not the end of the
Parker family's secrets though it turns
out that in addition to the parents he
never knew
Spidey also had a long-lost older sister
Teresa who was herself a SHIELD agent
after a team-up in which it was revealed
that her men
of the Parkers were falsely implanted by
Mephisto it turned out that was also a
ruse she was in fact Peters actual
sister after all
and even pitched in to help him fight
bad guys using her spy skills if you've
ever read any spider-man comic or seen
him in a movie or a cartoon or
encountered the character pretty much
anywhere then you've almost certainly
seen the motto that guides his life with
great power comes great responsibility
except Ben Parker never actually said
those words in amazing fantasy number 15
Spidey's often referenced motto is never
spoken out loud by any character not
even Uncle Ben instead it only appears
in a caption at the end of the story as
a moral lesson imparted by well Stan Lee
Spidey himself doesn't even say it until
25 years later in 1987 as time went on
though the phrase became more and more
identified with bhim largely because it
would be really weird for spider-man to
solemnly vow to accept the lesson that
was imparted to him through narration by
the guy who wrote his comics check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]